all right Gary tell us what's going on
for clean out the computer day so
Michael Rapaport sinner fantasy football
league has been a league for a long time
he's always a major pain in the ass he
made it to the finals this year for the
third time and he lost right
he was a loss to Richard how much did
you win in that fantasy for 1200 yeah
the sweetest victory is getting to beat
Michael Rapaport and the championships
is awesome like he calls Gary and JD all
the time and like screams with them
JD Sunday morning you know what that
means right it's time for [ __ ] I've
been [ __ ] every single person in this
league does he do that with you I won't
give him my number
I won't by four years he's tried he's
begged Sal for my number
Sal gives it gave him wants the number
so he can yell yeah and I don't need
that I don't need somebody yelling at me
on my personal time I usually don't like
to mix it up with him but after Richard
beat him I texted I was taunting I
couldn't resist what you saying I said
oh the humanity lost again you're the
Susan Lucci of this league I couldn't
write back [ __ ] you no no it's more like
he goes into this weird mood where it's
just like can't you see I'm in mourning
right now after he lost he'd have
Richards numbers but he didn't have
Sal's number so he left Sal 'voice mail
but mostly he just picked on me you got
hit yeah boomerang [ __ ] lost girl and
now I got that big tooth [ __ ] ate
that bull [ __ ] Bowie texted me it's
costing me in harassing me that's
[ __ ] animal did you see his picture
from a Rockefeller Center
how dare he poses in front of a
Christmas tree with those [ __ ] yellow
teeth [ __ ] the people were running for
their lives it's fear behind them and
he's got the [ __ ] nerve to be
harassing me well you you maybe I got
under his skin I like that so what
happened next so what happened next is
now it's time to get paid because he did
win as a runner-up he gets someone it
might be two or three outer box
right $400 yeah okay so we had the wrong
email address for him not offer he cheat
his email address and didn't tell us so
the money got sent somewhere he ended up
getting his money but at this point in
his voicemail he hasn't got his money
yet and he's threatening people I
guarantee you that that cow [ __ ] was
crispy got his money okay and then
everybody else was getting paid
throughout the year but I can't get my
[ __ ] money now so what are you a
[ __ ] church you can't answer the
phone prick what do you think a splitter
oh Jesus Christ needs to 400 that quick
huh
he wants his money what else you got so
then he lives in New York City sometimes
and sometimes there's a lot of
construction going on so this is I love
this he puts this on Instagram the video
they'll be working outside his apartment
he just starts screaming at all the
workers they don't [ __ ] stop
I
we're gonna toss up real it is real can
I tell my god he's got every right in
the world to feel that way yeah but he's
like on the 15th floor he's a tough guy
yeah he's yelling they can't hear I
don't know that he'd yell at them like
that yeah I think they can hear when's
the [ __ ] job gonna be over what are
you guys gonna be done clear the [ __ ]
building down man oh my god
imagine being his neighbor